hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game again from final
round of the altie box now a
championship 2019 this time I will not
be asking you to decide whether it's
classical or the Armageddon since we've
already seen the game from the classical
time format so obviously this is the
Armageddon the classical game was drawn
even though both Fabi and crossing had
their chance to win the game but it was
well very complicated crossing screen be
three super complicated but in the
Coronas case Magnus well accra wanna
just trusted Magnus on that one so
without further ado let's enjoy the
armageddon Fabi again with the white
pieces and he again opens with E 4 we
have c5 again repeating the same line
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and again Fabi
not interested in you know checking up
if Carson did any additional training in
the World Chess Championship line so
Bishop to b5 going again for the in the
for the ROFL emo with Knight to f6 by
Carlsen not Knight to c3 defending the
pawn and now Knight to d4 so already
mixing it up from from the start asking
why do you want to capture here but it's
a really it's not not a line that white
would enjoy for example if captures
captures now you would kick away the
defender of this pawn here black can
capture it and now yes you will capture
this pawn but after a6 Bishop e2 and
Queen b6 White has some problems here
you can't move the knight because of
Queen to F - checkmate if you play
something like d3 to kick away the
knight or give night for knight black
will just capture on f2 and only then we
capture the night and if you play
something like f3 a black will still
ruin your day by playing Knight to f2
and it's well it's just nothing white
white should go for so after constants
this night to d4 move we have E 5 by
Fabi the main move in this position
Knight captures on b5 we have Knight
captures on b5 and now Knight to d5 and
here Fabi goes for Knight to g5 so
already you can see that a lot of nights
are there in the center of the board and
you know neither Fabian or Carlsen are
interested in in developing their other
pieces or or pawns for that matter so
what do you do here it's a
it is a dangerous position if you play a
move like East six seems like a normal
developing move you're attacking the
night you know just defending the knight
on d5 white will make it very difficult
for black with 94 and now you can no
longer guard the d6 square so it's gonna
be very hard to play this and on the
other hand if you play something like h6
you're just asking for it I mean I've
captured some f7 captures and Queen f3
check attacks the knight on d5 so
probably Knight f6 blocking captures
captures and it just gonna be well you
don't want to play this with black so
here cross someplace f6 and again it's
one of those positions where it's
actually okay to play f6 this is the
main line in this well in this line and
here it's very interesting for example
there is a no move here
Queen to f3 Grisha played it in 2017
against Anton core oboe and want to get
a very nice game with it but here Fabi
goes for Knight to e4 it's an old move
Nakamura plated in 2002 in the in the
pan-american under-20 championship and
he won a very nice game with it so Fabi
goes for that with f5 are pushing the
knight back and now Knight to g5
repeating not all that great because
here East 6 is actually fine for black
are you attacking the knight after h4
gonna go Bishop e7 just Castle and well
bio black will have a very nice game so
after this if I move there the only
known move in this position was well
there is one game with Nyjah 5 line that
we've just shown but there are five
games in the database with c4 so this is
all known theory but here the move
Fabiano plays Knight B to C 3 is a new
move and it is now all ready for move 9
that we have a completely new game so if
you capture my knight I'm gonna capture
your knight the knight on d5 is
undefended and here cross and just
trades and goes d6 we have captures
captures and the d6 cousin says I'm very
happy with this position with castles by
Fabi and now D captors on e5 Magnus not
interested in you know he doesn't care
about doubling his pawns he always
somehow makes it work with Queen to e to
going to recapture d5 pawn and here just
east 6 now you might think
when it just defended with I'm like II
for well because all your pieces are
still undeveloped and protecting a pawn
in situations like these will most
likely cost you the game here what would
go rogue d1 prepared III just open up
lines and now if you prepare to develop
your Bishop and Castle d3 is coming
already White is threatening to open
lines and that none of your pieces are
developed so not something you want to
do so after Queen e2 with east six
crossing gives back d5 pawn with Queen
captures on e5 Queen to d6 now offering
a trade Fabi declines that Queen to e2
and now Bishop to e7 Magnus is ready to
castle will be three are preparing the
fiend cat of the dark square Bishop with
castles and now Bishop to b2 Bishop to
d7 cousin is now ready to put his Bishop
on this very nice diagonal and now rook
81 rook a to e8 cousin also wants to
control this this file and now Knight to
d1 making this Bishop a very strong
piece and also this bishop is probably
coming to f6 so you want to be ready for
that
Bishop to f6 by Carlsen Bobby traits
captures captures and not nice to be to
this Knight is now coming to c4 which
will come with an attack on the Queen
end from there the night is coming to e5
from where nothing will be able to
challenge it at night so if the knight
reaches 'if I've that will be a monster
night you don't have any pawns to kick
it away from a 5 and also Magnus has a
light square Bishop e5 is a dark square
so you definitely want to get this night
over to e5 Costin goes look to h6 he
threatens checkmate and pretty much asks
do you want to play h3 or do want to
trade Queens
Bobby decides it's time to trade Queens
with Queen to e5 Queen captures rook
captures and now b6 just defending that
pawn and favi goes a4 there's time for
this night to get the e5 doors and
nothing magnets can do to take care of
that so here we have an endgame where
the material on the board is equal both
players with two point islands one
differences Magnus has a bishop against
tonight but he also has a backwards e
six pawn which will be a weakness for
the rest of the game if Magnus will not
be able to do something
so Bishop the c6 first getting this
bishop to a very nice diagonal and now
a5 just trying to create weaknesses of
course if you captured and lose the c5
pawn with rook to b8 going after this
pawn here and now just a capture son b6
a capture son b6 and now d3 defending
the pawn and now rook to d5 Magnus wants
to trade here and Fabi says okay I'm
done with the trade but I want to get my
knight over here as soon as possible so
if we trade my knight gets there without
wasting any time
so here Crossan has a couple of chances
not chances ideas well your pawn here is
under attack so the idea is basically b5
and after b5 if captures you will play
pawn captures here you could play Bishop
captures but then your problem is after
Knight to e5 what do you play here let's
say before maybe try and create a
backward C to pawn here which it's hard
to say how you will take advantage of
this after f3 this bishop is just
useless it's not doing anything and it's
not gonna be doing anything for a very
long time this rook is gonna come into
the game this way and it's just a much
better position for white so here b5 is
the idea but then after captures you're
probably gonna have to capture with the
pawn and then after 95 just push f4 your
bishop is nicely protected here this was
one of the options Magnus had a
different plan he played Bishop to b5 of
course he wants to trade this Bishop for
night I mean who wouldn't
but Fabi says no way man rook captures
on b5 with it captures and now Knight to
e3 and here Carlson will lose a pawn
either the D pawn or the F pawn he
pushes d4 and Knight captures an f5 we
have looked at rotary sex grabbing hold
of the open e file and 5e now grabs hold
of the open a file so it's a bit of a
different setup now cost and decided to
give up one pawn but at least his pawns
are now on dark squares and for this
well being down upon his compensation is
that he will once again be able to
control this beautiful diagonal with his
bishop so ok bit of a trade-off but you
are you are down upon but again he does
have the black piece is the arm again
and he only needs it
we have King to f7 and now f3 making
some room for the King and taking care
of any background you know issues we
have King to f6 and not Knight back to
g3 now okay your knight will no longer
have an outpost on e5 but this is also a
very nice outpost we have looked at east
7 preventing rook to e7 and now Knight
to e4 check with King to e6 and out rook
to e8 and here Fabi is basically teasing
Magnus he's saying do you want to go
bishop c6 which will ensure you that you
can trade the best for night here I get
rid of your silly Bishop and you know I
grab my super night but it's actually
not the greatest idea here cross and
should just you know continue well not
that but bringing his King over to the
Queen side and try and hold this
position however he can but here Magnus
actually plays Bishop to c6 which is not
the greatest of plans so I feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out why Bishop the c6 is not the
greatest of moves I'll give you a couple
of seconds no I don't have my water
ready the glass is empty I forgot to
refill it
you know it's silly me but okay here for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent and
game player on a Saturday and for those
of you who just won't enjoy the show ruk
a6 the b6 pawn is undefended and here if
Bishop captures first you're gonna
capture the point and only then we
capture the bishop the problem is after
rook b7 now Bobby has Knight captures
and c5 with check and after you capture
then rook captures and c6 that's the
problem with Bishop to c6 so after
crossing Saudis he played Bishop
captures on e4 he saw that there was no
point defending the b6 pawn but now far
we just went rook after Sun b6 and now
if you move the king then Magnus will
get a passed pawn on e4 so not
interested in that Magnus says okay I'm
gonna give you back your pawn here but a
bishop here but without allowing you to
create a passed pawn here so rook
captures on c6 we have king to d5 and
now rope to a six so here Magnus was
able to go into the endgame but
he's down two points which is not not
something you want to do we have looked
to eat to buy Magnus a lot of activity
for his rook rook to a to defending the
c2 pawn and now King to c6
with H four by five e h5 and now King to
H do you also can go rook a king f1 kick
away the rook and then try to get your
king up the board but after Magnus hides
it on v2 you're not gonna be able to go
to the second ring so king h2 with King
to b6 and out King to g3 rook to d2 just
waiting there trying to keep this rook
at bay so this rook has to guard the c2
upon the King has to guard the g2 pawn
was so f4 by Fabi with g6 and now it
seems like you don't really have any
more useful moves for white but Fabi
makes it work king of three we have
kinked the b7 by Magnus and now b4 just
breaking open this pawn chain so if you
capture just the root b2 will capture
both pawns not much to it so here a
cross and tried a sneaky idea c4 but now
you get D captures on c4 in the d3 so
here it seems like Magnus managed the
wiggle his way out of a fishy position
but it's not really not really going his
way here because of course you cannot
capture as rookin a2 is hanging here we
have kinked III attacking the rook and
now well you have to play something you
can't afford this because this just
trades down into losing the King in pawn
and gain for Magnus so here at Magnus
tried rook captures and g2 King captures
on d3 and now we have looked to g4
magnet schools for the King side pawns
with rook to a5 going for Ruby g5 and
eliminating at least one of the pawns
rook captures on f4 with rook to g5 and
our rook captures on h4
we have rook captures and g6 and here at
Magnus played rope to h1 but it was also
in this position on new 52 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game as it's three
to one and it's not something you can
hold wife will just place c5 and you
will not even be able to deliver any
checks because whenever the King hides
you will also be able to just move the
pawn hide yourself behind the passport
not past but behind the phone and it
will just be very easy to win this game
so Magnus knows this and he decides to
resign the game here so very interesting
even though he only needed a draw here
it really didn't seem like he was
playing for a driving he was just having
fun as he already won the tournament and
you don't actually lose any rating
points for losing Armageddon so a very
interesting game to say the least and an
excellent victory for Fabiano Caruana
against Magnus in a window
in a game that he had to win as it is
Armageddon and also very interesting
let's check out the standings as we
didn't check him out Magnus Carlsen
wanted with 13 and a half points
followed by you Jungian level onion with
10 and a half then we have Khurana and
Wesley so with 10
dinkler in which eight and a half Maxime
buffer lagravis want an island with 8
and well Medea of in dogs and Russia
with five and a half and didn't really
have the greatest tournament but also
it's very important to see how the
Armageddon actually influences the
standings so if we look at it one more
time you can see that for example
Dingley and you can see that there are
no zeros there okay he lost a lot of
games in the Armageddon but he did not
lose a single classical game and he
won't to classical games the same as
Magnus Carlsen
but Crossan is first and Dingley reign
is sixth so if we didn't have armageddon
here we would basically have a tie
between Magnus cross and ending leerin
in first place for example because dink
lost pretty much all of his Armageddon's
he lost six Armageddon's four whereas
for example you young ji young he lost
to classical games one to classical
games but one pretty much all of his arm
again and I believe he lost one and he
got second place you know thanks to the
Armageddon
so it's very interesting even though you
don't mess up your rating due to
Armageddon it does affect affect the
standings quite a lot because here like
I said if it was only classical event we
would have a cross an ending tied for
first place but because it's also an
Armageddon then being is sixth and the
crossing is is you know clear first
which is very interesting if more and
more tournaments go into this well
format of the tournament then it's not
going to be enough you know to just have
good classical skills you will have to
be
you know the the the most complete in
every possible way you will have to be
able to play everything bullet rapid
blitz classical and I think I think the
future of chess is going in that
direction because everyone is I mean
okay classical is classical it's always
a shame to decide a classical tournament
or or match in a different time format
but people love it the games that you
know come out of Armageddon are super
exciting and you will very rarely see
such crazy games played in just
classical time format so I'm very
interested in how how the other
tournament organizers will look up to
this or maybe look down to this but you
know that's just the thing you know
things are happening you know I I think
chess has a very bright future so we'll
just have to wait and see where we're
this whole arm again I think you know it
takes us but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and this short
coverage of the altie box no way
championship I would like to thank Greg
Hampton Remington Roth and novel actin
jr. and MSH for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
video serie thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
I have some interesting videos coming up
and also we are going back to the
Capablanca saga up until the
Grantchester starts in zagreb thank you
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday